O
MERRICK GARLAND COULD NOT IN THE
AMERICAN TIGHTROPE.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HEADED.
>> Pete: WHAT IS THE REALITY?
WE DON'T PUT ANYTHING PAST THE
GARLAND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WE CAUGHT THIS NOTE IN THE
EIGHTH PARAGRAPH OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SWEEPING
ARTICLE ABOUT LAST NIGHT'S
FILING.
IN INCLUDING THIS TELLING LINE.
EIGHTH PARAGRAPH.
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS ARE NOT
EXPECTED TO FILE CHARGES
EMINENTLY.
IF THEY EVER DO AT ALL.
JOINING ME NOW IS NEWT GINGRICH,
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
NEWT, THE TRUMP LEGAL TEAM
RESPONDED TO THE DOJ CONTENDING
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT WOULD BE ON
THE PREMISES BY THE VERY NATURE
OF PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION?
>> MOST CORRUPT JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND ALL OF AMERICAN
HISTORY.
YOU HAVE CORRUPTION IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL INTO THE HEAD
OF THE FBI TO SENIOR ELEMENTS OF
THE FBI.
YOU HAVE COLLUSION FROM A WIDE
RANGE OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
YOU HAVE I THINK 50 SOME
INTELLIGENCE SENIOR OFFICIALS
WHO SIGNED A LETTER LAST YEAR
THAT WE NOW KNOW WAS A TOTAL
LIE, NONE OF WHOM HAVE RECANTED.
I FULLY EXPECT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO INDICT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN A D.C. COURT,
DISTRICT WHERE HE GOT 5.6% OF
THE VOTE.
BY 19-1 THE JURY IS LIKELY TO BE
AGAINST HIM.
I THINK THIS IS AN ALL-OUT
EFFORT.
ZUCKERBERG, THE FOUNDER OF
FACEBOOK SAYING THE FBI ASKED
HIM TO SUPPRESS THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP FOR THE THREE OR FOUR
WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION IN
2020.
OTHER TIME WHEN SOME 80% OF
AMERICANS SAY IF THEY HAD KNOWN
HOW CORRUPT HUNTER BIDEN AND
THROUGH HIM HIS FATHER WERE,
THEY PROBABLY WOULD HAVE VOTED
FOR JOE BIDEN.
-- PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE VOTED
I AM A HISTORIAN BY TRAINING AND
I TELL EVERYBODY YOU HAVE TO
ASSUME THAT NOTHING YOU KNOW
TELLS YOU ANYTHING ABOUT HOW
CORRUPT AND HOW SICK THIS IS
GOING TO GET.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE FANATICS WHO
REPRESENT A SECULAR RELIGION WHO
ARE DETERMINED TO DESTROY NOT
JUST TRUMP BUT TRUMP'S
FOLLOWERS.
THEY COULD DO ALMOST ANYTHING.
WE HAVE NO WAY OF KNOWING WHAT
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS OR TWO YEARS
ARE GOING TO CARRY.
>> Pete: AS A HISTORIAN, TO
SAY THE MOST CORRUPT, THAT SAYS
A LOT.
YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
CHARACTERIZING THEIR OPPONENTS
CHARLIE HURT HOW JOE BIDEN
CALLED TRUMP SUPPORTER
SEMIFASCIST.
HERE'S THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY DOUBLING DOWN.
>> THE PRESIDENT THINKS THERE IS
AN EXTREMIST THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CLEAR AS
HE CAN BE ON THAT PARTICULAR
PIECE WE TALK ABOUT A DEMOCRACY.
ONLY TALK ABOUT OUR FREEDOMS.
THE WAY THAT HE SEES THAT THE
MAGA REPUBLICANS ARE THE MOST
ENERGIZED PART OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
IT'S A EXTREME THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY, FREEDOM, RIGHTS.
>> Pete: POLITICAL OPPONENTS
OF THE BIGGEST THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY EVEN THOUGH WE ARE A
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC?
YOU SAY THIS IS THE MOST CORRUPT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT YOU'VE EVER
SEEN.
HOW DANGEROUS IS OUR MOMENT?
>> LOOK, I THINK THERE'S A BRIEF
PERIOD LATE IN THE WILSON
ADMINISTRATION WHERE YOU HAD AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO SORT OF
LOST HIS MIND AND HAVE ALWAYS
CALLED THE RED SCARE.
THEY LOCKED UP A LOT OF PEOPLE.
INCLUDING THE FORMER SOCIALIST
PARTY CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT.
IT WAS A VERY BRIEF PERIOD.
WHAT YOU SEE NOW IS AN
INSTITUTIONAL COMMITMENT THAT
RUNS FROM PLACES LIKE HARVARD
AND PRINCETON AND YALE TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"WASHINGTON POST" AND THE MAJOR
NETWORKS TO THE DEEP STATE, TO
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THE
FBI, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
ALL OF THESE SYSTEMS ARE NOW
BASICALLY AT WAR WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THIS IS THE THING BIDEN DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND.
IF YOU THOUGHT THE LAST ELECTION
WAS RELATIVELY FAIR AND I THINK
WE LEARNED MORE AND MORE ABOUT
HOW RIGGED IT WAS, EVEN IF YOU
THOUGHT IT WAS RELATIVELY FAIR,
73 OR 74 MILLION AMERICANS VOTED
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
HAVE A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CHARACTERIZED,
HALF OF HIS COUNTRY, THE WAY
JOE BIDEN IS, THE GREATEST ACT
OF AGGRESSION BY AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT AGAINST HIS OWN PEOPLE
THAT WE HAVE EVER SEEN.
IT'S TRULY AN ASTONISHING
MOMENT.
IT DOESN'T FIT ANY OF OUR PRIOR
HISTORY.
I KEEP TELLING MY FRIENDS, DO
NOT ASSUME ANYTHING BASED ON
PAST PRESIDENT BECAUSE YOU ARE
NOT DEALING WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
TERRIFIED.
IF YOU'RE THE SENIOR FBI OREO
THE WHITE HOUSE AND YOU ARE
LOOKING AT THE POTENTIAL OF A
REPUBLICAN CONTROLLED THE
HOUSE AND SENATE YOUR EMAILS,
YOUR MEETINGS, EVERYTHING YOU'VE
BEEN DOING COULD SUDDENLY BECOME
PUBLIC AND YOUR ENTIRE CAREER
COULD BE DESTROYED AND YOU MIGHT
END UP IN JAIL, I MEAN, YOU'RE
GOING TO DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN
TO TRY TO GUARANTEE THAT THE
REPUBLICANS CAN'T WIN THIS FALL
BECAUSE YOU'RE TERRIFIED OF WHAT
A REPUBLICAN CONGRESS WOULD BE
LIKE.
>> Pete: AND THEN THAT FEELS
LIKE A CYCLE THAT DOESN'T STOP,
AS AMERICANS NEEDS ARE NEVER MET
BECAUSE THEY ARE TOO BUSY